-Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much
going on right now.
The NFL Draft kicked off
tonight in Las Vegas.
That's right. Elon Musk is
buying Twitter for $44 billion.
We got our first look at the
sequel to "Avatar."
And Chipotle says that they want
to start offering dessert.
There's a lot to go over.
[ Laughter ]
So let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, the NFL Draft got
under way tonight in Las Vegas.
The best
college football players
are heading to the pros,
where they're going to make
a lot of money,
almost enough money to...
buy Twitter.
Elon Musk is buying
the company for $44 billion.
The whole thing came together
really fast, unlike...
"Avatar 2."
It's been
13 years in the making.
And they're calling it
"The Way of Water,"
which is also what you hear from
the bathroom after eating...
Chipotle dessert.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Word of warning --
don't stand behind anyone
who eats it
or you might feel a...
draft.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Hey, Tom Brady wasn't picked
until the sixth round.
He waited longer to get drafted
than we've waited for...
"Avatar 2."
Those "Avatar" characters have
some unusual names,
like Neytiri, Mo'at, and...
Elon Musk.
He's taking
a big risk with Twitter
and he might regret it,
kind of like eating...
Chipotle dessert.
If it's anything like the guac,
it'll cost...
$44 billion.
So, in conclusion...
[ Cheers and applause ]
welcome to the NFL...
welcome to a living hell...
finally here, what a shocker...
think ahead, call a doctor.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪